सुर्णगी रुसी आस्रम, महारानी अस्तान बहडिया स्तान, सुर्य मंदीर, बाला त्रिपुरा सुन्री स्तान, जलब पास्तान, ये सब भी को प्रणाम करकर मेरी बात की सुरुआत करता हूँ
आज मैं लखी सराय आया हूँ तब, बिहार के पहले मुख्यमंत्री, बिहार के स्री, स्रीकृष्ण बाबु को भी मन पूर्वक प्रणाम करना चाहता हूँ
स्रीकृष्ण बाबु ने ही, चैदा साल तक, बिहार के विकास की नीव रखने का काम किया
स्रीकृष्ण बाबु के समय में ही, बिहार भारत के प्रमूख राज्यों में से एक राज्य बना
जिसको आगे चल कर लालू रबडी ने जंगल राज से बरबाद कर दिया, जंगल राज से बरबाद
भाईयों बेनो 6 नवंबर को मत्तान है, आप सभी को कमल और तीर के निसान पर बटन दबाना है
मगर आप ऐसा सोच कर मत दबाईयेगा, कि आपके वॉट से कोई विदायक बनेगा, कोई मंत्री बनेगा, कोई उपमुक्य मंत्री बनेगा
आप इस समझ कर वॉट दीजेगा, आपका एक एक वॉट नितिजी और मोदी जी के नेत्रुतों में
विक्सित बिहार बनाने के लिए वॉट है विक्सित बिहार
जंगल राज को रोकने वारा बोर वॉट है
और भाईयों बेनों मैं तो जीसी जीले में जाता हूँ
वो सभी जीलों में कहते हैं भाई साब हमारे प्रत्यासी को मंत्री बना देना
और लखी सराइवारणों आपको तो हमने बना बनाया उप मुक्य मंत्री आपके यहां बेद दिया है
भाईयों बेनों ए लखीरी सराइगा सिंदूर और गुलाल दोनों बहुत प्रसीद है
प्रसीद है ना भाई अरे जोर से बोलो है ना
सिंदूर और गुलाल दोनों इस चुनाओं में बहुत महत्यों पूर्ण पदार्थ
मैं आज आपको बताने आया हूं ए लालू और सोनियागी की सरकार थी
केंद्र भे उसने इस देश में आतंकवाद के लिए अपनी वोट बेंक के लिए लचिला स्टेंड रखा था
आये दिन पाकिस्तान से आये हूए आतंकवादी खुन खराबा करते थे अपनी धर्ती को लव लुआन करकर चले जाते थे
कोई कूछ नहीं बोलता थे दोजार चौदा में आप सभी ने नरेंदर मोदीधी को ब्रदान मंत्री बनाया
और उसके बाद जीतने भी जीतने भी आतंकी हमले हुए पहले सर्जीकल स्ट्राइक की फिर एर्श्ट्राइक की और पहल गाउं में जब हमला हुआ
आप्रेशन सिंदूर करकर पाकिस्तान के घर में घुश कर अतंकीों का सफाया करें यह लखी सराई का सिंदूर
यहां क्या जो सिंदूर है वो सिर्फ सिंदूर नहीं है हमारी माता और बेहनों का सौभाग्य का निसान है
और मोदी जी ने वो यात्रियों का बद्दा लेने के लिए जो ओप्रेशन चलाया इसको ओप्रेशन सिंदूर नाम देकर
हमारी माता बेहनों का सन्मान पूरे विश्व में बढ़ाने का काम किया है
मोदी जी के सासन में ये देश नकसलवाद मुक्त हो रहा है
आतांकवाद से मुक्त हो चुका है और ब्रश्टा चार से भी मुक्त हो चुका है
भायो बेनो लखी सराई का एक एक वोट लसी सराई का एक एक वोट जंगल राज की मुक्ति नकसलवाद की समाप्ति और आतांकवाद के खिलाप द्रड़ अभियान के लिए कमल के फूल और तीर के निसान पर देना है
मुझे बताईए भायो बेनो आप लोग देंगे या नहीं देंगे
भायो बेनो मैं आपको बताने आया हूँ
2005 के पहले पूरा बिहार जंगल राज की चटपेट में था
सारे उद्योग बंद, व्यापार बंद, धंदे बंद, ट्रेडिंग बंद
एक ही धंदा चल रहा था अपहरण और फिरोती
जगन्य अत्याकांड होते थे, नरसंगार होते थे
खून, अपहरण, फिरोती, चरम सिमा पड़ था
और किसके राज में था, लालू रबडी के राज में, था या नहीं था भई, बताओ दो जरा, जोर से माता है बेने भी बताए, था या नहीं था
मैं आपको बताना चाहता हूँ, आपने नितीस बाबू के हाथ में बिहार का सासन दिया, नितीस बाबू ने जंगल राज को समाप्त कर दिया, समाप्त कर दिया
और बिहार के अंदर नए विकास की सुरुवात, मैं आज आपको कह कर जाता हूँ, एक और बार NDA की सरकार बनाईए, यह जो नीव, मोदी जी और नितीस जी ने डाली है, वो नीव पर एक बड़ी इमारत खड़ी करने का काम हमारी सरकार करेगी
भायो बैनो अभी अभी, अभी अभी कल राहूल बाबा आए थी, मोदी जी को अप्मानित करने के लिए कुछ सब्द बोलें, मगर उन्होंने, मोदी जी को अप्मानित करतें करतें छट मैया का अप्मान किया हैं, उन्होंने कहा, छट मैया की पुजा करने वाले नोटंकी क
राहुल बाबा आप क्या समझो छट मैया का महत्व छट मैया के प्रती पुरे देश की स्रद्धा आप नहीं समझ पाओगे आपकी माता जी भी नहीं समझ पाएगी
छट मैया का अपमान करने का बदला इस बार बिहार का एक एक वाटर देगा और मोदी जी के लिए अब सब्द बोलते हो जरा इतियास उठा कर देख लो जितनी जितनी वार
मोदी जी के लिए कॉंग्रेस के नेताओं ने अब सब्द किये कॉंग्रेस का सुपड़ा साफ हो गया है सुपड़ा साफ हो और राहुल बाबा आप मान कर चलना
आपके कारेकर्दाओं ने मोदी जी की माता जी को अपमानित किया आपने मोदी जी के लिए अब सब्द कहे और आपने छट मईया का अपमान किया है
यह बिहार है बिहार जब चौदा तारीक को डबे खुलेंगे दूर दूर तक गट बंदन साफ हो जाए
और भाईयों वेनों जो विजए जुलूस दिकलेगा वो विजए जुलूस लखी सराइखे गुलाल से ही गुलाबी हो जाएगा
लखी सराइखा गुलाल पूरे बिहार को गुलाबी करेगा जब फीर से एकमार Nडिय की सरकार बनेगे
भारतिय जन्ता पार्टी ने हमने एक कार्यकर्टा के रूप में यहाँ विजय सिनाजी को भेजा था, मैं तो आपका धन्यवाद करने आया हूँ,
लखी सरायवालो, मैं कह कर जाता हूँ, फिर से विजय बाबू को विदायक बनादो, हम उनको बड़ा आदमी बनाने का काम करेंगे.
भाईयों बेहनों ये चुनाओ ये चुनाओ विक्सीत बिहार बनाने का चुनाओ ये किसानों की बात करते हैं विजय जी जब कुरुशी मंत्री थे बहड़िया में उन्होंने दलहन विकास केंद्र सापित किया कोल शोलेज और गोदाम बनाए
अलसी कुरुशी फाम में सीड हब का निर्मान कराया और सेंटर फॉर एक्सेलेशन भी बनाया और आज मैं आपको बताने आया हूं ये लालू राबडी राहुल जी गुमते हैं भाईयों बेनों धान का MSP का दाम
2014 में तेरा सो दस रुपया था तेरा सो दस कितना था बोलो तो जरार अरे जोर से बोलो कितना था
मोदी जी ने तेरा सो दस से बढ़ा कर चोबी सो रुपया करने का काम नरेंदर मोदी में किया
मक्के का दाम तेरा सो दस रुपया था और खरीदा भी नहीं जाता था
जाता थेरा सो दस से बढ़ाकर मोदी जी ने चोबी सो रुपया दाम करने का काम किया है
चोबी सो रुपया और इद्धनल के जो प्लांट लगाए हैं जितना मक्का बिहार के किसान उगाते हैं
सभी का सभी इथेनौल बनकर पेट्रोल की जगे लोगों की गाड़ी में जाता है मोदी जी ने बिहार के खेती को समरूद किया
गेहु में भी चौदा सो की जगे पची सो पचासी MSP की चने में इकती सो की जगे उनसट सो रुपया किया और खरीदी भी साड़े छे गुना बढ़ाने का काम किया है
लखी सराय में 1570 करोड रुपये से 1232 एकड में सोलार प्रोजेक लगाया गया 95 करोड से कियूल नदी के किनारे
STP बनाया गया 26 करोड से कियूल लखी सराय को जोडने वाला बेली ब्रिज के निर्मान की बात की
अमरूत भारत ट्रेन अमरूत भारत के तहट लखी सराय धेलवे स्टेशन को करोडों रुपया खर्च करकर नया बनाने का क्याम
82 करोड से पीपराही में एंजिनरिंग कॉलेज का उद्गाटन किया और लखी सराय वालों बच्चों को मेडिकल में डाखला दिलाना है न तो पटना नहीं जाना पड़ेगा दिल्ली नहीं जाना पड़ेगा
अगले दो साल में अपने लखी सराय में मेडिकल कॉलेज खुलने वाला है और मैं आज कहकर जाता हूँ
लखी सराय मेडिकल कॉलेज का नाम बिहार केसरी स्रिकुष्ण बाबू के नाम पर हम रखने वाला है
भायों बेनों पंद्रा करोर से असोग घाम मंदीर का विकास किया
पंद्रा करोर से कुसी उत्पादन बजार समीति को आधुनिक बनाए यह सब तो किया
मोदी जी ने बिहार के अंदर धेर सारे और काम किये हैं मैं बाद में बताऊंगा
मगर मुझे बताओ विसेश करे माताय बहने बताएं लालू रबडी ने कुछ किया था क्या
इसे नहीं वही जोर से बताओ लालू रबडी ने कुछ किया था क्या जरा पीछे वाले भी बताएं जोर से कुछ किया था
ऐसा नहीं है लखी सराय वालो
आप अन्याए करे घर ओ लालू जी के साथ
बिचारे बुजूर्ग आदमी को क्यों अन्याए कर इन्होंने कुछ किया है
बताओ क्या किया
मैं बताओ
जोर से पुचुंगा बताना बोलना लालू जी ने किया है
बताओ मैं
बोलो भई चारा गोटाला किसने किया जोड से बोलो किसने किया लेंड पूर जोप सकेम किसने किया होटल बेखने का गोटाला किसने किया अलग तरह गोटाला किसने किया
बाढ़ रहत गोटाला किस ने किया? ए भी एक्सपोर्ट का गोटाला किस ने किया? आई से अधीख संपती का गोटाला किस ने किया?
रे भाई ए छोटे मिया तो छोटे मिया बड़े मिया भी सुभान लालू राबडी ने तो यहां ए गोटाले करे उनके बड़े नेता है राहुल बाबा
कॉंग्रेस ने भी दस साल में 12 लाग करोड के घपले घोटाले और ब्रश्टाचार किया है मुझे बताओ करोड'
करोडर रुपय का ब्रश्टाचार करने वाले ला लू रड़ी और कॉंग्रेस बिहार का भला कर सकते है
जिरा जोड से मोलो कर सकते हैं। 20 साल हो गए नितिज बबु को और नरेंदर मोदी जी को 11 साल हो गए, दोनों पर चार आने का ब्रष्टा चार का आरोप नहीं लगा है, चार आने का ब्रष्टा चार, पूरा पेसा गरीबों के लिए खर्च,
अभी अभी नितिज इने 1 करोड 21 लाख जीवी का दिदी के बेंक अकाउंट में 10 जार रुपईया डालने का काम, भारतिय जन्ता पार्टी के नेता नरेंदर मोदी और नितिज कुमानी,
और मैं जीवी का दिदियों को बताना चाहता हूं, यहां से रुकने वाला नहीं है, दस अजार रुपिया आपको मिला, अब आपको 2 लाख तक का लौन देने का काम,
NDA सरकार करने वाली है 2 लाख रुपे का, हर घर में 125 युनिट बीजली फ्री कर दी, पटना में मेट्रो बन रहा है,
युवाओं को बेरोजगारी ब्रत्था एक हजार प्रतिमा मिल रहा है, विद्वा पेंचन 400 से बढ़ा कर हमने 1100 किया,
बुजुर्गों का पेंचन 400 से बढ़ा कर 1100 किया, आसा बेहने और आंगन वाडी का हमने मान दे बढ़ा है,
और मोदी जी ने बिहार के विकास के लिए 18,00,00 करोड रुप्या खर्चे, 4,00,00 करोड सडक और पूल के लिए खर्चे,
औरdriving में 1,000,000 करोर्ड मखाना बॉड की स्थापना की पूनियाँ एरपोर्ट बनाया, दरभंगा एरपोर्ट बनाया, दरभंगा में एम्स बनाया, तेन, तेरा Greenfield Expressway और industrial कोरिडोर बनाये
और हजारों मेगावाट बिजली के कारखाने डाले भायो बेनों इसके अलावे बिहार में आठ करोड बावन लाग गरिबों को पाँच किलो अनाज हर महिना मुफ्त में देने का काम हमने किया
87 लाग किसानों को 6,000 रुपिया प्रतिसाल देने का काम किया हमने 44 लाग घर बना कर दिये है बिहार के लिए और 33 लाग घर देने का कारेकरम चल रहा है
एक करोड 17 लाग बेनों को उजवला घैस का सिलिंडर दिया एक करोड 33 लाग सोचाले बनाए और 3 करोड 53 लाग लोगों को पाँच लाग तक का पूरा इलाज का खर्चा मुफ्त में करने का काम नरेंद्रम मोदी देने के
भायो बेनों यह सब तो किया है मगर मैं आज आपको कुछ और बताना चाहता हूँ
बाबर ने साड़े 500 साल पहले अयोध्या में रामलला का मदनीर तोड दिया
इसको मुगलों ने नहीं बनने दिया अंग्रेजों ने भी नहीं बनने दिया और कॉंग्रेस ने भी नहीं बनने दिया
नरेंद्र मोदी जी ने अयोध्या में राम मंदीर का भूंभी पुजन भी किया और प्राण प्रतिष्टा करकर जय स्रीरा
मुझे बताओ भी और वालो राम मंदीर बनना चाहिए था यह नहीं बनना चाहिए था
जोर से बलो बनना चाहिए था या नहीं बनना चाहिए था
ए लालू राबडी कॉंग्रेस सभी लोग राम मंदिर का विरोध कर रहे थे
मगर राम मंदिर तो बना दिया मोदी जिने
अब मैं कहने आया हूँ सीता माता हमारे बिहार की बेटी है सिहार की
और जैसा भव्य मंदीर अयोध्या में बना रहे पुनोरा धाम में साड़े आठ सो करोड थे भव्य सिता माता का मंदीर भी बनने वाला है
और मंदीर बनते ही हम सिता मड़ी से अयोध्या सीधी ट्रेन लगाने वाले हैं जो अयोध्या जाएगा वो अयोध्या से सीधा सीधा माता का दर्सन करने अपने बिहार में आएगा
भायो बेनो ये लालू राबडी राहुल हमारे देश की संस्कृति का सन्मान ने अभी राहुल बाबा आये थे दो महिना पहले गुस पेटिया बचाओ ये आत्रान का मैं लखी सराय वालों को पूछना चाहता हूं विहार की मत्ताता सुची में बंगलादेशी गुस पेट
लालू जी राहुल जी कान खोड़ कर सुन लो जितनी यात्रा निकालनी है निकालो बिहार से हम एक एक गुस पेटिये को चून चून कर निकालेंगे एक एक गुस पेटिया
हमारे गरीबों में रोजगारी के लिए स्पर्दा करता है गरीबों का अनाज इसमें बटवारा करता है और देश विरोधी कृत्य भी करता है बिहार की ये पवित्र भुमी पर हम गुस पेटियाओं को नहीं सहन करेंगे उनको चून चून कर निकाल दिए
लखी सराय वालों मुझे बताओ गुस पेटियाओं निकालने में लखी सराय वाले भाजपा के साथ है या नहीं है जोर सबलो है या नहीं है अंडिये के साथ है या नहीं है
तो आप लोगों को छे तारी को जलपान करने से पहले मत्दान करना है
और कमल के निसान और तीर जो भी हो मसिन पर उसको बटन दबना है
मुझे बताओ भाई कमल के निसान पर बटन दबाओगे क्या
जोर से बलो दबाओगे
तीर पर बटन दबाओगे
देखो लखी सराए वालो बटन जरूर दबाना
मगर इतने घुस्से से दबाना कि बटन तो लखी सराए में दबे
उसका करन्ट इटली में जाकर लगे इटाली में जाकर
मोदी जी का हात मद्बूत करोगे
जोर से बलो करोगे
निती जी का हाथ मद्बूत करोगे
हमारे विजय बाबू को जिताओगे
मंदल जी को जिताओगे
तो मेरे साथ दोनों हाथ उठाईए
उठाईए दोनों हाथ
विजय के संकल्प की मुठी भीचे
और प्रचंड आवाद से बोलिए
भारत मता की
वन दे
जय श्री राम
जय जय श्री राम
असोग दाम मंदिर
जिसको इंद्रत दमन्वेश्वर मंदिर भी कहते है
मैं भी वहाँ जाकर
आसिरवाद लेकर आया हूँ
असोग दाम मंदिर को भी
प्रणाम करकर मेरी बात की सुरुआत करता हूँ
बायो वेनो
सुरुंगी रुसी आस्रम
महारानी अस्तान बहडिया स्तान
सुर्य मंदिर
बाला त्रिपुरा सुंद्री स्तान
जलब पास्तान
ये सब भी को
प्रणाम करकर मेरी बात की सुरुआत करता हूँ
आज मैं लखी सराया आया हूँ तब
बिहार के
पहले मुख्यमंत्री
बिहार के स्री
स्रीकृष्ण बाबु को भी
मन पूर्वक प्रणाम करना चाहता हूँ
स्रीकृष्ण बाबु ने ही
14 साल तक
बिहार के विकास की
नीव रखने का काम किया
स्रीकृष्ण बाबु के समय में ही
बिहार
भारत के प्रमूख राज्यों में से
एक राज्य बना
जिसको आगे चल कर
लालू रबडी ने
जंगल राज से बरबाद कर दिया
जंगल राज से बरबाद
भायो बेनो 6 नवंबर को मत्ता नहे
आप सभी को
कमल और तीर के निसान पर बटन दबाना है
मगर आप ऐसा सोच कर मत दबाईएगा
कि आपके वाट से
कोई विदायक बनेगा
कोई मंत्री बनेगा
कोई उपमुक्य मंत्री बनेगा
आप इस समझ कर वाट दीजेगा
आपका एक एक वाट
निती जी और मोदी जी के नेत्रुतों में
विक्सित बिहार बनाने के लिए वाट है
विक्सित बिहार
जंगल राज को रोकने वारा वाट है
और भाईयो बेनो
मैं तो जीसी जीले में जाता हूँ
वो सभी जीलों में
कहते हैं भाई साब हमारे प्रत्यास्री को
मंत्री बना देना
और लखी सरायवार नो
आपको तो हमने
बना बनाया
उप मुक्य मंत्री आपके
यहाँ बेद दिया है
भाईयो बेनो
ए लखीर सराय का
सिंदूर और
गुलाल
दोनो बहुत प्रसीद है
प्रसीद है ना भाई
अरे जोर से बोलो है ना
सिंदूर और गुलाल
दोनो इस
चुनाव में
बहुत महित्व पूर्ण पदार थी
मैं आज आपको बताने आया हूँ
ए लालू और सोनियागी की सरकार थी
केंद्र में
उसने इस देश में
आतंकबाद के लिए
अपनी वोट बेंक के लिए
लचिला स्टेंड रखा थी
आये दिन
पकिस्तान से आये हुए आतंकवादी
खुन खराबा करते थे अपनी धर्थी को लव लुआन करकर
चले जाते थे
कोई कूछ नहीं बोट थे
2014 में
आप सभी ने
नरेंदर मोदीधी को ब्रदान मंत्री बनाया
और उसके बाद
जीतने भी
जीतने भी आतंकी हमले हुए
पहले
सर्जीकल स्ट्राइक की
फिर एर्श्ट्राइक की
और पहल गाओं में जब हमला हुआ
ओप्रेशन सिंदूर करकर
पाकिस्तान के घर में घुषकर
आतंकीों का सफाया
यह लखी सराई का सिंदूर
यहां क्या जो सिंदूर है
वो सिर्फ सिंदूर नहीं है
हमारी माता औ बेहनों का सौभाग्य का निसान
और मोदी जी ने
वो यात्रियों का बद्दा लेने के लिए
जो ओप्रेशन चलाया
इसको ओप्रेशन सिंदूर नाम देकर
हमारी माता बेहनों का सन्मान
पूरे विश्व में बढ़ाने का काम किया है
मोदी जी के सासन में
ये देश नकसलवाद मुक्त हो रहा है
आतांकवाद से मुक्त हो चुका है
और ब्रश्टा चार से भी मुक्त हो चुका है
भाईो बेनो लखी सराई का एक एक वोट
लसी सराई का एक एक वोट
जंगल राज की मुक्ति
नकसलवाद की समाप्ति
और आतांकवाद के खिलाब
द्रड अभियान के लिए
कमल के फूल और तीर के निसान पर देना है
मुझे बताईए भाईो बेनो
आप लोग देंगे या नहीं देंगे
भाईो बेनो
मैं आपको बताने आया हूँ
2005 के पहले
पूरा बिहार
जंगल राज की चटपेट में थे
सारे उद्योग बंद, व्यापार बंद, धंदे बंद, ट्रेडिंग बंद
एक ही धंदा चल रहा था
अपरण और फिरोती के जगन्य अत्यकांड होते थे
नरसंगार होते थे
खून, अपरण, फिरोती
चरम सिमा पड़ था
और किसके राज में था?
लालू रबडी के राज में
था या नहीं था भई बताओ दो जरा?
जोर से माता है, मैंने भी बताए था या नहीं था?
मैं आपको बताना चाहता हूँ
आपने नितीस बाबू के हाथ में
बिहार का सासन दिया
नितीस बाबू ने जंगल राज को समाप्त कर दिया
और बिहार के अंदर नए विकास की सुरुवात
मैं आज आपको कह कर जाता हूँ
एक और बार
NDA की सरकार बनाई है
यह जो नीव, मोदी जी और नितीस जी ने डाली है
वो नीव पर एक बड़ी इमारत खड़ी करने का काम हमारी सरकार करेगी
भायो बेनों, अभी अभी
अभी अभी कल राहूल बाबा आए थी
मोदी जी को अपमानित करने के लिए कुछ सब्द बोले
मगर उन्होंने
मोदी जी को अपमानित करते करते
छट मईया का अपमान किया है
उन्होंने कहा
छट मईया की पुजा करने वाले नौटंकी करते हैं
नाटक करते हैं
इरे राहूल बाबा
आप क्या समझो
छट मईया का महत्व
छट मईया के प्रथी पुरे देश की स्रद्धा
आप नहीं समझ पाओगे
आपकी माता जी भी नहीं समझ पाएगी
छट मैया का अपमान करने का बदला
इस बार बिहार का एक एक वाटर देगा
और मोदी जी के लिए अब सब्द बोलते हो
जरा इतियास उठा कर देख लो
जितनी जितनी वार
मोदी जी के लिए कॉंग्रेस के नेताओं ने अब सब्द किये
कॉंग्रेस का सुपड़ा साफ हो गया है
और राहुल बाबा
आप मान कर चलना
आपके कारेकरताओं ने
मोदी जी की माता जी को अपमानित किया
आपने मोदी जी के लिए अपसब्द कहे
और आपने छट मईया का अपमान किया है
ये बिहार है बिहार
जब चोदा तारीक को चोदा तारीक को डबे खुलेंगे
दूर दूर तक गट बंदन साफ हो जाएगा
और भाईो वेनो जो विजय जुलूस निकलेगा
वो विजय जुलूस लखी सराय के गुलाल से ही गुलाबी हो जाएगा
लखी सराय का गुलाल पूरे बिहार को गुलाबी करेगा
जब फीर से एक मार एंडिये की सरकार बनेगा
भारतिय जनता पर्टी ने हमनें एक कारे कर्था के रूप
में यहां वजय सिनाजी को भेजा था में तो आपका धन्यवाद
करने आया हूं हमने एक कारे कर्था भेजा था आपने उसको विधान सभा
जबाद द्यक्स तक पहुंचाया हमने कारेकरता भेजा था आपने उसको उपमुख्यमंत्री तक पहुंचाया लखी सरायवालो मैं कहकर जाता हूं फिर से विजय बाबू को विधायक बना दो हम उनको बड़ा आदमी बनाने का काम करेंगे
भाईयो बेहनो ये चुनाव विक्सित बिहार बनाने का चुनाव एक किसानों की बात करते हैं विजय जी जब कुशी मंत्री थे बहड़िया में उन्होंने दलहन विकास केंद्र सापित किया
सीड हब का निर्मान कराया और सेंटर फॉर एकसेलेशन भी बनाया और आज मैं आपको बताने आया हूं ये लालू राबडी राहुल जी गुमते हैं भाईयो बेहनो धान का
में स्पि का दाम 2014 में तेरा सो दस रुपया था तेरा सो दस कितना था बोलो जो जरार अरे जोर से बोलो कितना था
मोदी जी ने 1310 से बढ़ा कर 2400 रुपया करने का काम Narendar मोदी ने किया
मक्के का दाम 1310 रुपया था और खरीदा भी नहीं ज़ाता था
तेरा सो दस से बढ़ा कर मोदी जी ने चौबी सो रुपिया दाम करने का काम किया है
और इथेनौल के जो प्लांट लगाए है जितना मक्का बिहार के किसान उगाते है
सभी का सभी इथेनौल बनकर पेट्रोल की जगे लोगों की गाड़ी में जाता है
मोदी जी ने बिहार के खेती को समरूद किया
गेहु में भी 1400 की जगे 2585 मस्पी की चने में
3100 की जगे 6900 रुपिया किया और खरीदी भी 6.5 गुना बढ़ाने का काम किया है
लखी सराय में 1570 करोड रुपिये से
1232 एकड में सोलार प्रोजेक लगाया गया
95 करोड से कियूल नदी के किनारे
स्टीपी बनाया गया 26 करोड से कियूल लखी सराय को जोडने वाला
बेली ब्रीज के निर्मान की बात की अमरूद भारत ट्रेन
अमरूद भारत के तहट लखी सराय धेलवे स्टेशन को करोडो रुपिया खर्च करकर
नया बनाने का काम किया बैसी करोड से पीपराही में
एंजिनेरिंग कॉलेज का उद्गाटन किया और लखी सराय वालो बच्चों को
मेडिकल में डाखला दिलाना है न तो पटना नहीं जाना पड़ेगा दिली नहीं जाना
अगले दो साल में अपने लखी सराय में मेडिकल कॉलेज खुलने वाला है और मैं आज कहकर जाता हूं
लखी सराय मेडिकल कॉलेज का नाम बिहार केसरी स्रीकुष्ण बाबू के नाम पर हम रखने वाले हैं
भायो बेनो पंद्रा करोर से असोग दाम मंदीर का विकास किया
पंद्रा करोर से कुछी उत्पादन बजार समीति को अधुनिक बनाए ये सब तो किया
मोदी जी ने बिहार के अंदर ढेडर सारे और काम किये हैं मैं बाद में बताओंगा मगर मुझे बताओ
विसेसकारे माताय बेहने बताए लालू रबड़ी ने कुछ किया था क्या
ऐसे नहीं बही जोर से बताओ लालू रबड की ने कुछ किया था क्या
जरा पीछे वाले भी बताए जोर से कुछ किया था ऐसा नहीं है लखी सराय वालोग आप अन्याय करें ओ लालू जी के साथ बिचारे बुजूर्ग आदमी को क्यों अन्याय करें इन्होंने कुछ किया है बताओ क्या किया है
मैं बताओं जोर से पुछूँगा बताना बोलना लालू जी ने किया है बताओं मैं बोलो भई चारा गोटाला किस ने किया जोर से बोलो किस ने किया
लैंड पर जोब सकेम किस ने किया होटल बेतने का गोटाला किस ने किया अलग तरह गोटाला किस ने किया
बाररहाद गोटाला किस ने किया ए बी एक्सपोर्ट का गोटाला किस ने किया आई से हधीक संपती का गोटाला किस ने किया
रे भाई ए छोटे मिया तो छोटे मिया बड़े मिया भी सुभानल लालू राबडी ने तो यहां ए गोटाले करे उनके बड़े नेता है राहुल बाबा कॉंग्रेस ने भी दस साल में बारा लाग करोड के घपले गोटाले और ब्रश्टाचार किया है
मुझे बताओ करोड़ो रूपय का ब्रश्टाचार करने वाले लालू राबडी और कॉंग्रेस बिहार का भला कर सकते हैं क्या जरा जोड से बोलो कर सकते हैं
बीस साल हो गए नितिस बबु को और नरेंदर मोदी जी को ग्यारा साल हो गए
दोनों पर चार आने का ब्रश्टाचार का आरोप नहीं लगा है
चार आने का ब्रश्टाचार पूरा पेशा गरीबों के लिए खर्च अभी अभी नितिजी ने
कि एक करोड़ 21 लाख जीवी का दिदी के बेंक अकाउंट में दस जार रुपईया डालने का काम भारतिय जनता पार्टी के नेता
नरेंद्रमोदी और नितिज कुमारी और मैं जीवी का दिदियों को बताना चाहता हूं यहां से रुकने वाला नहीं है
दस जार रुपिया आपको मिला अब आपको दो लाख तक का लॉन देने का काम एंडिये सरकार करने वाली है दो लाख रुपे का हर घर में
125 युनिट बीजली फ्री कर दी पटना में मेट्रो बंदा है यूवाओ को बेरोजगारी ब्रत्ता एक अजार प्रतिमा मिल रहा है
विद्वा पैंचन 400 से बढ़ाकर हमने 1100 किया बुजुर्गों का पैंचन 400 से बढ़ाकर 1100 किया आसा बेहने और आंगन वाडी का हमने मान दे बढ़ा है
और मोदी जी ने बिहार के विकास के लिए अठारा लाग करोड रुपया खर्चे चार लाग करोड सडक और पूल के लिए खर्चे और रेलवे में एक लाग करोड मखाना बौर्ड की स्थापना की पूणिया ऐरपोर्ट बनाया दर्भंगा एरपोर्ट बनाया दर्भंगा मे
और इंडस्ट्रियल कोरिडॉर बनाए और हजारों मेगावोर्ट बिजली के कारखाने डाले भायो बेनों इसके अलावे बिहार में आठ करोड बावन लाग गरिबों को पांच किलो अनाज हर महिना मुफ्त में देने का काम हम ने किया
87 लाग किसानों को 6,000 रुपिया प्रतिसाल देने का काम किया हमने 44 लाग घर बना कर दिये है बिहार के लिए और 33 लाग घर देने का कारेकरम चल रहा है
एक करोड 17 लाग बेनों को उजवला घैस का सिलिंडर दिया एक करोड 33 लाग सोचाले बनाए और तीन करोड 53 लाग लोगों को पांच लाग तक का पूरा इलाज का खर्चा मुफ्त में करने का काम नरेंद्रमोदी देने के
भायो बेनों यह सब तो किया है मगर मैं आज आपको कुछ और बताना चाहता हूँ
बाबर ने साड़े पांच सो साल पहले अयोध्या में रामलला का मदनीर तोड दिया
इसको मुगलों ने नहीं बनने दिया अंग्रेजों ने भी नहीं बनने दिया और कॉंग्रेस ने भी नहीं बनने दिया
नरेंद्र मोदी जी ने अयोध्या में राम मंदीर का भुंबी पुजन भी किया और प्राण प्रतिष्टा करकर जय स्रीरा
मुझे बताऊ भी ओर वालो
राम मंदिर बनना चाहिए था या नहीं बनना चाहिए था
जोर से बनो बनना चाहिए था या नहीं बनना चाहिए था
यह लालू राबड़ी کंग्रेس
सभी लोग
राम मंदिर का विरोथ कर रहे थे
मगर राम मंदिर तो बना दिया मोदी जिने अब मैं कहने आया हूँ सीता माता हमारे बिहार की बेटी है, सिहार की बेटी
और जैसा भव्य मंदीर अयोध्या में बना रहे, पुनोरा धाम में
साड़े आठ सो करोड थे
भव्य सिता-माता का मंदीर भी बनने वाला है
और मंदीर बनते ही
हम सिता-मडी से आउद्या
सीधी ट्रेन लगाने वाले है
जो आउद्या जाएगा
आउद्या से सीधा
सीता-माता का दर्शन करने अपने बिहार में आएगा
भायो बेनो ये लालू राबडी राहुल हमारे देश की संस्कृति का सन्मान ने अभी राहुल बाबा आये थे दो महिना पहले गुस पेटिया बचाओ या अत्रान का मैं लखी सराय वालों को पूछना चाहता हूं विहार की मत्ताता सुची में बंगलादेशी गुस पेटिय
लालू जी राहुल जी कान खोड़ कर सुन लो जितनी यात्रा निकालनी है निकालो बिहार से हम एक एक गुस पेठिय को चून चून कर निकालेंगे एक एक गुस पेठिया हमारे गरीबों में रोजगारी के लिए स्पर्दा करता है
गरीबों का अनाज इसमें बटवारा करता है और देश विरोधी कृत्य भी करता है बिहार की ये पवित्र भुमी पर हम घुस पेठियाओं को नहीं सहन करेंगे उनको चून चून कर निकाल दिए
लखी सराय वालों मुझे बताओ गुस पेठिया निकालने में लखी सराय वाले भाजपा के साथ है या नहीं है
जोर से बलो है या नहीं है एंडिये के साथ है या नहीं है तो आप लोगों को छे तारीकों जलपान करने से पहले मत्दान करना है
और कमल के निसान और तीर जो भी हो मसिन पर उसको बटन दबाना है
मुझे बताओ भाई कमल के निसान पर बटन दबाओगे क्या जोर से बलो दबाओगे तीर पर बटन दबाओगे
देखो लखी सराय वालो बटन जरूर दबाना मगर इतने घुसे से दबाना की बटन तो लखी सराय में दबे
उसका करंट इटली में जाकर लगे इटाली में जाकर लगे
मोदी जी का हाथ मद्बूत करोगे जोर से बोलो करोगे
निती जी का हाथ मद्बूत करोगे अमारे विजय बाबू को जिताओगे मंदल जी को जिताओगे
तो मेरे साथ दोनों हाथ उठाईए उठाईए दोनों हाथ विजाई के संकल्प की मुठी भीचे और प्रचंद आवाद से बोलिए बारत मता की वंदे वंदे जैस्री राम
जैस्री राम असोग दाम मंदीर जिसको इंद्रत दमन्वेश्वर मंदीर भी कहते हैं मैं भी वहाँ जाकर आसिरवाद लेकर आया हूं असोग दाम मंदीर को भी प्रणाम करकर मेरी बात की शुरुवाद करता हूं
बायो वेनो सुरुंगी रुसी आस्रम महारानी अस्तान बहड़िया स्तान सुर्य मंदीर बाला त्रिपुरा सुन्द्री स्तान जलब पास्तान ये सब भी को प्रणाम करकर मेरी बात की शुरुवाद करता हूं
आज मैं लखी सराया आया हूं तब बिहार के पहले मुख्यमंत्री बिहार के स्री कृष्ण बाबु को भी मन पूर्वक प्रणाम करना चाहता हूं
स्री कृष्ण बाबु ने ही 14 साल तक बिहार के विकास की नीव रखने का काम किया
स्री कृष्ण बाबु के समय में ही बिहार भारत के प्रमूख राज्यों में से एक राज्य बना जिसको आगे चल कर लालू रबडी ने जंगल राज से बरबात कर दिया जंगल राज से बरबात कर दिया
भायो बेनो 6 नवंबर को मत्ता नहें आप सभी को कमल और तीर के निसान पर बटन दबाना है
मगर आप ऐसा सोच कर मत दबाईएगा कि आपके वोट से कोई विदायक बनेगा कोई मंत्री बनेगा कोई उपमुक्य मंत्री बनेगा
आप इस समझ कर वोट दीजेगा आपका एक एक वोट निती जी और मोदी जी के नेत्रुतों में विक्सित बिहार बनाने के लिए वोट है
जंगल राज को रोकने वारा बोट है और भाईयों बेनो मैं तो जीसी जीले में जाता हूं वो सभी जीलों में कहते हैं भाई साब हमारे प्रत्यासिकों मंत्री बना देना और लखी सरायवार्णों आपको तो हमने बना बनाया उपमुक्य मंत्री आपके यहां बेद दिया
भाईयों बेनों ए लखीरी सराय का सिंदूर और गुलाल दोनों बहुत प्रसीद है प्रसीद है ना भाई अरे जोर से बोलो है ना
सिंदूर और गुलाल दोनों इस चुनाओं में बहुत महत्व पूर्ण पदार्थ थी
मैं आज आपको बताने आया हूँ ए लालू और सोनियागी की सरकार थी केंद्र में उसने इस देश में आतंकबाद के लिए
अपनी वोट बेंक के लिए लचिला स्टेंड रखा था आये दिन पाकिस्तान से आये हूए आतंकबादी
खुन खराबा करते थे अपनी धर्थी को लव लुआन करकर चले जाते थे कोई कोछ नहीं बोलता थे
2014 में आप सभी ने नरेंदर मोदी जी को ब्रदान मंत्री बनाया
और उसके बाद जीतने भी जीतने भी आतंकी हमले हुए पहले सर्जीकल स्ट्राइक की फिर एर्श्ट्राइक की और पहल गाउं में जब हमला हुआ
आप्रेशन सिंदूर करकर पाकिस्तान के घर में घुश कर अतंकीों का सफाया करें यह लखी सराई का सिंदूर
यहां क्या जो सिंदूर है वो सिर्फ सिंदूर नहीं है हमारी माता और बेहनों का सौभाग्य का निसान है
और मोदी जी ने वो यात्रियों का बद्दा लेने के लिए जो ओप्रेशन चलाया इसको ओप्रेशन सिंदूर नाम दे कर
हमारी माता बेहनों का सन्मान पूरे विश्व में बढ़ाने का काम किया है
मोदी जी के सासन में ये देश नकसलवाद मुक्त हो रहा है आतांकवाद से मुक्त हो चुका है और ब्रश्टा चार से भी मुक्त हो चुका है
भायो बेनो लखी सराई का एक एक वोट लसी सराई का एक एक वोट जंगल राज की मुक्ति नकसलवाद की समाप्ति और आतांकवाद के खिलाप द्रड अभियान के लिए कमल के फूल और तीर के निसान पर देना है
मुझे बताईए भायो बेनो आप लोग देंगे या नहीं देंगे भायो बेनो मैं आपको बताने आया हूँ
दो जार पांच के पहले पूरा बिहार जंगल राज की चटपेट में थे शारे उद्योग बंद व्यापार बंद धंदे बंद ट्रेडिंग बंद एक ही धंदा चल रहा था अपरण और फिरोती
जगन्य अत्यकांड होते थे नरसंगार होते थे खून अपरण फिरोती चरम सिमा पड़ और किसके राज में था लालू रबड़ी के राज में था या नहीं था भई बताओ दो जरा जोर से माताय बेने भी बताए था या नहीं था
मैं आपको बताना चाहता हूँ आपने नितीस बाबू के हाथ में बिहार का सासन दिया नितीस बाबू ने जंगल राज को समाप्त कर दिया
और बिहार के अंदर नए विकास की सुरुवात मैं आज आपको कह कर जाता हूँ एक और बार
एंडिये की सरकार बनाईए ये जो नीव मोदी जी और नितीस जिन्ने डाली है वो नीव पर एक बड़ी इमारत कर खड़ी करने का काम हमारी सरकार करेगी
भायो बेनों अभी अभी अभी कल राहूल बाबा है थी मोदी जी को अपमानित करने के लिए कुछ सब्द बोले मगर उन्होंने मोदी जी को अपमानित करते करते
छट मंए का पमान किया है उन्होंने कहा छट मंए की पुजा करने वाले नोटंकी करते हैं नाटक करते हैं अरे राहूल बाबा आप क्या समझो छट मंए का महत्व छट मंए के प्रतीपुरे देश की स्रद्धा आप नहीं समझ पाओगे
आपकी माता जी भी नहीं समझ पाएगी
छट मैया का अपमान करने का बदला
इस बार बिहार का एक एक वाटर देगा
और मोदी जी के लिए अब सबत बोलते हो
जरा इतियास उठा कर देख लो